that he's apologized now we've got to
move on because his agenda is packed the
country's to-do list is enormous he's
about to fly off by the way to india
where he's probably unsuccessfully going
to try and uh fail to try and persuade
narendra modi to toughen his line on
ukraine and also talk to them about
migration the other kinds of bilateral
issues that you've got there but also
you've got the cost of living crisis he
wants to move on and he's going to make
out uh that that it's time to because
he's apologizing but the truth for the
tories and the truth for boris johnson
is that he can't because guess what now
we've got not just weeks probably months
of this to come you heard it from nigel
mills just now you've got the question
of whether or not the police threw out
more fines for boys johnson personally
and who else they threw up fines for
you've got the question of what sue
gray's report says that doesn't begin to
be written until after the police
concluded their job uh and then you've
probably got to wait until the other
side of the local election so so start
of june middle of may end of may start
of june that's when nothing's about this
really comes to a head
then the second truth is a truth for the
labour party talking to kirstama's
closest allies today they fully admit
that this is really difficult for them
to because there's only so much that you
can on the opposition benches point and
sneer and jibe and jab at the prime
minister and make political headway
because this is for conservative mps to
be judge jury and executioner you play a
bit part role and you're not talking
about people's everyday lives their
everyday concerns when you're talking
about party games but to what extent
then
do occasions like this serve to shape
the minds we're seeing the conservative
benches starting to fill here they will
be sitting there and they will be
looking not just of course at the prime
minister not just at those opposite not
even just at those up in the press
gallery but at their phones to see
exactly what the reaction is to the
prime minister speaking
oh neil you're asking a really horrible
question
because the truth about that is that
what we're going to see in the next 40
minutes probably isn't going to be
transformative politics actually whisper
it quietly we make it try and seem
exciting every single day and we try
very hard we don't always succeed
but the truth is that this is happening
over a slightly longer time scale this
is six weeks this is eight weeks uh to
decide what to do about boris jones and
that's the time scale that the tory
party have got so the point about today
is do the opposition and those critics
within the conservative party keep up
the pressure today is there another tory
credit critic to add to the 14 that we
have had so far how does boris johnson
conduct himself does he continue to
inspire and carry as much confidence as
he is capable of at the moment but
presuming that we don't get more critics
and we don't get um a mess up by boris
johnson things will continue as is for
some weeks to come so yes important but
today isn't quite d-day
just keeping an eye on the commons
because of course yesterday is your 15
minutes of tele uh demonstrated
sometimes
28 minutes with telly sometimes the
prime minister not quite in his seat as
early as possible just just a word
though on what is happening tomorrow in
terms of the numbers they're not going
to win the opposition aren't they in
terms of the vote to compel the
privileges committee to get involved uh
this is a vote in the commons over
whether or not there should be inves an
investigation into whether or not boris
johnson lied the tory is effectively
going to try and stop that vote of
course they have the numbers boys
johnson won an 80-seat majority there
was a minor tactical question about
whether they concede in order to stop
allegations that the tories are
complicit in a cover-up there's probably
going to be some fancy plans westminster
wangle in order to stop that allegation
uh but whether it works or not
ultimately they're gonna block that
investigation uh well the prime minister
has just sat in his seat uh we'll just
wait a second let's wait for the for the
speaker i mean look boris johnson you
know he is a good communicator whether
or not you agree with which with the way
in which he does communicate you know he
does serve to touch a nerve quite a lot
of the time he would have thought about
this occasion won't he uh he will and
he is effective
in these in these moments
uh but also you can't escape the fact
that actually
slowly over time a bit like the air
going out the balloon he is less popular
than he once was his ratings in the
polls have taken quite a battering uh
and so he may not be the electoral
talisman by the electoral magic that he
once did
well the speaker is up the prime
minister's still sitting down uh one
assumes that this will be happening in
just a second and there we go the prime
minister i know the whole house will
want to join me in wishing her majesty
the queen a very happy birthday for
tomorrow
mr speaker this morning i had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today i will then be traveling to india
to deepen the strategic trade defense
and people-to-people ties between our
two countries building on india's
involvement in the carbus bay g7 summit
i'll be seeing prime minister modi in
delhi meeting indian business people
investing in the uk and visiting british
investments in india yeah talk to neil
thank you mr speaker
challenges with rural transport remain
some of the greatest obstacles facing
people in penrith and the border and i
was pleased last year to see on top of
the government's three billion pound
national bus strategy helping areas like
cumbria that cumbria county council
received an additional one and a half
million pounds to enhance provision as
part of the rural mobility fund but i'm
sure my right honor friend can only
imagine my disappointment this month
when cumbria was allocated no funding
from the latest tranche of bus funding
can the prime minister reassure my
constituents that cumbria can look
forward to future funding schemes to
improve our vital rural bus services
hi minister okay mike i thank my own
friend he's a great champion for uh
rural cumbria and for and for bus
services and uh he's right that can't
bring another 1.5 million pounds uh we
do for buses uh we do want to put more
into buses i believe them passionately
myself and i will make sure that he has
a meeting with the relevant minister
we don't come to the leader of the
opposition
thank you mr speaker can i join the
prime minister in wishing her majesty a
happy birthday
why did the prime minister's press
secretary allegra stratton have to
resign from her job
minister
that's right i i bitterly regret
allegra's resignation i think it was
very sad and i think she did an
outstanding job
but
i i do i i do particularly particularly
uh since she was the the one who coined
the uh expression coal cars cash and
trees which enabled the uk uh to deliver
a fantastic cop 26
summit last year
[Music]
allegra strucken laughed at breaking the
rules
she resigned the prime minister then
claimed he was furious at her behavior
and accepted her resignation
professor neil ferguson broke the rules
he also resigned
the prime minister said that was the
right thing to do
the former health secretary broke the
rules he too resigned
the prime minister tried to claim he
sacked him
why does the prime minister think
everybody else's actions have
consequences
except his own yeah
i i thank the right honourable gentlemen
i see i feel he's in some kind of doctor
who time warp but we had this we had
this conversation yesterday uh mr
speaker and i think i've ex i've
explained uh why i bitterly regret uh
receiving an fp and i i apologize uh to
the house uh but he asks about the
actions which i take responsibility now
i'll tell him we're gonna get on with
delivering for the british people uh
making sure
and making sure that we power out of the
the problems that kovid has left us and
more people in work than there were
before the pandemic mr speaker fixing
our energy problems and leading the
world in standing up to the aggression
of vladimir putin those are all subjects
about which i think he could reasonably
ask questions now
[Applause]
these are strange answers from a man who
yesterday claimed to be making a humble
apology
[Music]
does the prime minister actually accept
that he broke the law
mr speaker i've been absolutely clear
that i i humbly accept what the uh what
the police have
said i've paid the fixed penalty notice
and mr speaker what i think the country
and what i think the whole house i would
really rather do is get on with the
things for which we were elected deliver
on our promises to the british people
and if you could not have clearer
evidence of the intellectual bankruptcy
they have no plans they have no plans
for energy
and they have no they have no plans
to fix the economy
sit down i want to hear what you've got
to say but i can't hear when you're
talking that way i'm here in the church
please if you can help me no i think
we'll love that
the state of it the party of peel and
churchill reduced to shouting and
screaming
in defense of this lawbreaker
[Applause]
no then that's the last time that
parolee that you just asked about you
might have to go and take it i don't
know anymore or else you will be
drinking clear stuff
so mr speaker yesterday's apology lasted
for as long as the prime minister
thought necessary to be clipped for the
news
but once
once the cameras were off
once the cameras were off the prime
minister went to see his backbenchers
and he was back to blaming everyone else
he even said that the archbishop of
canterbury had not been critical enough
of putin
in fact the archbishop called putin's
war
an act of great evil and the church of
england has led the way in providing
refuge to those fleeing
would the prime minister like to take
this opportunity to apologize for
slandering the archbishop
[Applause]
speaker i i i think the
the right honorable gentleman uh i i was
i was slightly taken aback to be uh for
the gov sorry mr speaker i was slightly
taken aback for the government to be
criticized over the policy that we have
uh devised to uh end the end the deaths
at sea in the channel as a result of
cruel criminal gangs i i was surprised
uh to be that we were attacked for that
and actually mr speaker it turns out
that that policy do you know who
proposed that policy uh first of all
in 2004
it was david blunkett uh mr speaker
who said it was a 21st yes it was and
you'll remember a 21st century solution
to the problems of illegal asylum
seeking and immigration uh he should
stick with he's a corbin easter he's a
corbyn eastern a smart islington suit
that's the truth
i think you'll find mr corbin doesn't
have the whip but i think that's a no
then
pathetic he never takes responsibility
for his words or action
they were all there the prime minister
also accused the bbc of not being
critical enough of putin
would the prime minister
but the prime minister have the guts to
say that
to the face of clive myery
least doucet and steve rosenberg who
have all risked their lives day in day
out on the front line in russia and
ukraine uncovering putin's barbarism
[Applause]
if the right honourable gentleman wants
to uh join the conservative party and
come and listen to uh what uh the
meetings of the uh conservative he's
welcome to do it uh but though
as i say i think he's a corbynist in the
listington suit but i said nothing of
the kind
and i have the highest admiration as a
as a journalist and a former journalist
for what journalists do
i think they do an outstanding they do
an outstanding i mean i think he should
withdraw what he just said it has
absolutely absolutely
absolutely no basis or foundation in
truth
here's dharma
that's how he operates a merely mouthed
apology when the cameras roll
a vicious attack on those who tell the
truth as soon as the cameras are off
slander decent people in a private room
let the slander spread without the
backbone to repeat it in public
how can the prime minister claim to be a
patriot when he deliberately attacks and
degrades the institutions of our great
country
sorry mr speaker
mr speaker not not premise just just to
say
i want to hear the prime minister's
answers i expect it both ways prime
minister
[Music]
uh mr speaker there's a a an indication
of the depths to which he's willing to
see that he accuses me
he accuses me he accuses me of producing
journalists
what he says what he says is completely
without any foundation whatever
i did not attack the bbc last night for
their coverage of ukraine he must be out
of his tiny mind mr speaker
i said i said no such thing and there
are people behind who will testify to
that he is completely wrong mr speaker
that that is that is the limit that is
the limit of his willingness to ask
sensible questions today uh we are
getting on this government is getting on
with the serious problems that require
attention fixing our energy uh supply
issues and making and by the way i'm
doing the damage of the labor government
that didn't invest in nuclear power for
13 years
we're the nuclear power station every
year standing up to putin mr speaker
when uh he would have elected a putin
apologist that's what he wanted to do
and he campaigned uh to do that mr
speaker and fixing our economy with
record numbers of people now in work
productivity back above what it was
more than half a million people back on
the payroll than there were before the
pandemic began mr speaker that is as a
result of the decisions the tough calls
this government has make
we get on with the job while they flip
flop around like beach flanders on the
beach mr speaker
[Applause]
be about a
thank you
thank you mr speaker
founded in hitching by an inspirational
man called richard lucas the govox
mental wellbeing platform was started in
2018 following the sad loss of some
local young men to suicide
since then working with brilliant
partners like nhsx kings college london
and others the technology platform and
support services have grown to support
over the support the mental well-being
and mental health of over 40 000 young
people
in over 10 countries
today
govox is launching its campaign to offer
its services free to over a thousand
state secondary schools
would the prime minister welcome this
initiative perhaps go to hitchin and
meet the people from govox and secondly
could he set out could he set out what
more we can do to help young people and
young men with the problems of mental
health and mental well-being
yeah
i thank him very much i thank my
honorable friend i'm very pleased to
hear about the work that gov gobox is
doing to support mental health and and
well-being and we're putting more money
into mental health care uh support and
an extra 2.3 billion a year uh in the
next uh financial year uh which of
course we can uh supply thanks to the
decisions taken by this government uh
which actually that party opposed
we now come to the leader of the snp in
blackfood
thank you mr speaker can i join the
prime minister and leader of the
opposition and wishing her majesty to
queen best wishes for our birthday
tomorrow
mr speaker last night the prime minister
might have convinced his backbenchers
and his spineless scottish tories to
keep him in place for another few weeks
but the public
aren't so easily fooled 82 of people in
scotland said they believe the prime
minister lied to this parliament and to
the public about his law-breaking covert
parties
are they right
or should they not believe their lying
eyes
yeah prime minister i i thank the the
right normal gentleman uh we had a long
conversation about this yesterday uh i
uh understand the point of this question
but we are going to get on with the job
of delivering for the people of the
whole of the united kingdom
[Music]
the prime minister wants to get on he
should be offering his resignation to
the queen before her birthday mr speaker
no government can be led by a prime
minister who's in a constant state of
crisis to save his own skin and what's
worse
the uk government is now led by a tag
team of scandal a prime minister who
can't be trusted with the truth
and a chancellor who can't be trusted
with his taxes
everyone knows
that this prime minister is now on board
with time until the 20 back ventures
count the cost
of their council election defeat
but in the meantime
families are counting the cost of
authority-made
cost of living crisis every day
after yesterday's farce
isn't it finally the time for him to
accept that neither his party or the
public can afford to keep him around as
prime minister for one minute longer
prime minister
mr speaker
if that if that were true then uh i
don't think he'd be calling for my
resignation that's what we're going to
do is get on uh with the job in hand and
that is deliver for the entire people of
this country and and and by the way mr
speaker uh he hasn't answered the point
i made yesterday which i think is still
incredible uh that at a time when we
need to stand up to aggression uh from
vladimir putin it is still the party uh
still the policy of the scottish
nationalist party to get rid of this
country's uh unilateral uh defense
we have a close question phillip
hollerberg for three sir
i i thank my uh honourable friend he's
an excellent champion for for kettering
and we're fully committed to the
delivery of the new hospital for
catering the release of funding will be
subject to the usual business case
assessment process
the redevelopment of kettering general
hospital is the number one local
priority for residents in kettering and
across north northamptonshire would my
right honourable friend be kind enough
pleased to facilitate a meeting with the
health secretary for the three members
for kettering wellingborough corby
together with the hospital chief
executive so that we can trigger the
start of the drawdown of the initial 46
million pounds worth of funding yes
prime minister uh uh yes mr speaker my
writer from the health tech who told me
uh that he's met them before and he's
happy uh to meet them uh again there's
several roberts
platt camry have been calling for 15
years
for a law
to ban politicians
from being willfully misleading
new polling new polling by compassion
and politics shows that 73 of people
support such a law
will the prime minister support
a lying in politics bill
mr speaker it is it is well known it is
well known that the rules of this house
uh demand that we tell the truth in this
house and that's what we all try to do
nick fletcher
thank you mr speaker pmq's for the
constituency mp like me is a wonderful
opportunity to ask the prime minister
for a new hospital for doncaster maybe
or maybe for doncaster to be the home of
great british rail headquarters sadly mr
speaker there is a more pressing issue
and that is that men are dying so much
younger than they should so will the
prime minister meet with me to discuss
the merits of having a minister for men
and the benefits of a men's health
strategy
that way the next time i am fortunate
enough to get a pmq i can lobby the
prime minister for a new hospital for
doncaster and for doncaster to be the
home of great british rail headquarters
prime minister
uh i i thank my friend uh our honourable
friend very much for his uh his work in
this in this area and uh we are we are
determined to uh tackle uh all the uh
the health conditions that he's uh that
he's uh described and cares about uh
particularly mental health uh and uh and
and suicide prevention and i note his uh
his plea for a new hospital i know it's
one that's shared by many colleagues uh
on on these benches this is the
government that is funding that making
it possible thanks to the decisions uh
we've taken uh allowing our economy to
grow which would not have been possible
if we listen to them
thank you mr speaker on this side not
only do we believe that law breakers
can't be lawmakers but also that tax
raisers should be taxpayers
and when people in powerful positions
pick and choose where they pay their
taxes that's an insult to everyone else
who doesn't have that luxury so can i
ask the prime minister how many members
of his cabinet have ever been involved
in a tax avoidance scheme
[Applause]
mr speaker what we try to do in this
in this government is cut taxes uh for
the whole country and i'm proud to say
that what the chancellor did in the
recent spring statement uh by lifting
the threshold lifting the threshold for
uh national insurance contributions was
to have a tax cut for about 330 pounds
for most people in this country that's a
fantastic thing
sarah atherton
mr speaker if you live in north wales
and want to watch international sports
you have to travel four hours to cardiff
or swansea shock the wrecks and race
course with its historic cop stand is
home to wembley bound wrexham football
club
it's the oldest international stadium
in the world
and forms part of our leveling up fund
bids would the prime minister agree that
round two of the leveling up fund offers
an excellent opportunity to level up
access to sports
uh well there could be no no better
campaigner
for wrexham uh and for the interests of
wrexham sport uh i will do what i can uh
mr speaker but uh uh she'll know that uh
121 million uh from the first round of
the uh leveling up fund was awarded uh
to wales and i'm sure that wrexham which
i'm sure wrexham has every chance of
success in the future
christian
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
has been asked about sodium valparaise
scandal previously but sean linton at
the sunday times this weekend revealed
that campaigners were blacklisted
including my constituent emma murphy who
is here in the gallery today
advice from the cumberlands report has
been ignored warnings are still not on
medication as of a couple of weeks ago
and the redress scheme is still not
forthcoming will the prime minister meet
with me and campaigners like emma to
discuss what can be done to right this
incredible role
i thank you very much for raising the
the point uh i understand that we've had
a a review already of the uh of the
issue but i'll make sure that he has a
uh a proper meeting or he and uh the
campaigners that he meant just have a
proper meeting with the relevant
minister in the health department robert
generate thank you mr speaker my
constituent aiden aslan has served in
the ukrainian armed forces for four
years
last week he was captured by the russian
army in mariopol
yesterday a video emerged of my
constituent handcuffed
physically injured
and being interviewed under duress for
propaganda purposes
would my right honourable friend agree
with me that this is a flagrant breach
of the geneva convention
that treating any prisoner of war in
this manner is illegal
and that the interviewer graham phillips
is in danger of prosecution for war
crimes and that any online platform such
as youtube which hosts propaganda videos
of this kind should take them down
immediately
[Applause]
uh i i thank my right honourable friend
very much and i think everybody uh will
want to uh
uh will urge the russian uh state uh to
treat uh his constituent to humanely and
compassionately because in my view uh
although we do not encourage people in
fact we actively dissuade people from
going to that theater of conflict uh i
understand uh that he'd been serving in
the ukrainian forces uh for some uh time
and his situation was very different
from uh that of a a mercenary mr speaker
i hope that he is treated with care and
compassion i thoroughly uh echo the
sentiments that my right honourable
friend has expressed about those who
broadcast uh propaganda messages
mr speaker this conservative government
is raising taxes on working people in
the middle of a cost of living crisis so
can i press the prime minister on
whether he agrees that it would add
insult to injury if his chancellor or
any other government ministers were to
benefit from overseas tax havens in
their personal tax affairs
mr speaker
good point mr speaker but
but we are responsible for cutting taxes
for everybody which is what we're
actually doing
well
thank you mr speaker uh mr speaker
newcastle underlying is receiving over
50 million pounds of government
investment into our high street and the
high street in kidsgrove in my
neighboring my honourable friends
neighboring constituency but it's all
being overshadowed by the ongoing
environmental disaster at wally's quarry
in january the operator was hit by three
category one breaches by the environment
agency my constituents are utterly sick
of it it's been going on for far too
long prime minister we need to see
tougher enforcement we need to see the
permit taken away what hope can you give
my constituents how can we stop the
stink
thank you mr speaker my my honorable
friend has raised this issue before and
i know how uh how infuriating it is for
his constituents that's why my right
honourable friend the environment
secretary has now ordered action against
the site operator and permanent capping
will begin on site uh next month i can
tell him uh that will improve things for
thousands of residents in his uh
contingency and if it is necessary to
take uh further action uh to remove
these uh malodorous vapors uh mr speaker
then we will look joel
thank you mr speaker with details of the
sugary report trickling out a flood of
photos of partygate yet to be released
and any number of fixed penalty notices
liable to be leaked this is a prime
minister that's not fit to run a bath
never mind
it's time for him to stop this
ridiculous charade that he believes no
rules were broken
so will he commit to making public every
fixed penalty notice he receives
will he publish the party photos taken
by the official photographer and ensure
sue grace for sue grey's report is
published at the earliest opportunity we
have a right to know the truth
[Applause]
on the fixed pen on my own fixed penalty
notices i've i've been transparent with
the house i i apologize on the on the
rest of it uh on the rest of it and and
will be mr speaker but on the rest of it
i really think as i've said before uh
that the house should wait to the
conclusion of the uh investigation when
sue gray will be uh finally reporting
so john hayes thank you mr speaker long
ago in a far off place
thousands of british servicemen sailed
into what for them was the unknown as
they witnessed the early tests of
nuclear weapons they've lived with the
consequence of the service to our nation
ever since
following a pmq from the honourable
member for salford the promises agreed
to meet me and her
and those veterans but will he now
assure the house that he will take
personal charge
of the decision on whether to grant the
remaining servicemen for there are few
left the service medal they say richly
deserve yeah minister i i thank him very
much thank my right honourable friend
very much i thank him for uh campaigning
on this issue which i know attracts
support across the house and i i
certainly will take personal charge of
the mata myself and uh make sure that
they receive the uh the recognition they
deserve please twist mr speaker
my constituents across blade and knew
the rules and stuck to the rules
nurses and teachers included
no after work drinks for them
the prime minister set these rules night
after night he was on national tv to
exhort us to stick to the rules for
everyone's sake yet he continues to say
that he doesn't think he broke any rules
my constituents are angry that while
they stuck to the law the prime minister
broke it trust in his government is
broken so when will he go
mr speaker i understand the uh the
feelings of her constituents and i've
i've i continue to uh express my uh my
my apologies for uh the fpn that i i
received uh but what the government is
going to do is get on uh with tackling
the the issues that face this country
and delivering for the british people
and that is my priority
mr robert
thank you mr speaker one of my
constituents like many others across our
country has been helping directly with
the humanitarian effort in ukraine and
the region and he received the most
troubling message from a resident of the
city of cursin only days ago and i quote
from part of it there are no green
corridors for evacuation people are
trying to flee the city at their own
risk under fire the russians are living
in our homes they are plotting terror
robbing harassing kidnapping and killing
our people doing whatever they want mr
speaker what more can my right
honourable friend and the international
community do to ensure that putin and
those who do his bidding are brought to
justice for their crimes yeah yeah prime
minister
well i i think that he my royal friend
is making an incredibly important point
because the the savagery that the uh
russians are now unleashing on uh
ukraine clearly is uh knows no limits
and he's clearly authorized from the
very top and she asked what more we can
do i think what we need to do is make it
clear to uh serving officers now in the
russian forces uh that they will uh if
we uh can proceed with the international
uh criminal uh prosecutions that we want
to see they will eventually face justice
in the way that those uh who
participated in massacres in bosnia uh
face justice as faith justice in the
past and i hope mr speaker that that
will have a chilling effect on on their
current appalling conduct nick smith
mr speaker
every week
examples emerge of government waste
during covet
and last year the former health
secretary told me that there'd be no
profiteering and no cronyism
does the prime minister still agree with
him
prime minister mr speaker i think that a
lot of people uh made money i'm sad to
say out of uh out of covid uh in a way
that perhaps they shouldn't have done uh
and i and we we deplore that and we are
trying to recoup as much as we possibly
can but i would just i would just remind
him of the a constant clamor uh from
those benches and around the country for
us to equip our country with ppe uh with
medicines as fast as possible and that
we did mr speaker
russell thank you mr speaker
[Applause]
would the prime minister join me in
thanking the brilliant staff and
volunteers at watford general hospital
for their tireless work hope for our
community over many years and would he
agree with me that we should get started
as soon as possible on the ambitious
plans put forward by west hearts
hospital trust as part of the new
hospital program to transform health
care across our whole community so staff
and patients can access world-class
health services in facilities fit for
the 21st century and mr speaker if i may
add the ambitious plans are truly shovel
ready i will gladly go and buy a shovel
today to get started
uh well uh mr speaker that uh he is a
fantastic champion for watford and uh
and he's been he's back i know that
because
i've been to see him several times he's
been campaigning on this issue to get a
hospital in walford ever since he was uh
triumphantly elected and he's going to
be successful uh because there will be a
new hospital scheme in his local area
and uh it's part of our plan to deliver
48 new hospitals in this country by 2030
mr speaker richard thompson yeah yeah
thank you mr speaker the prime
minister's fundamental political problem
at the moment isn't about parties or
fixed penalty notices or cake
it's about the lack of trust integrity
and credibility at the heart of
government which he himself now
personifies
mr speaker when is the prime minister
going to realize that people don't want
to hear any more glib half-hearted
non-apologies or hearing witter on about
getting on with the job they just want
this pinocchio prime minister to pack
his bags and go
[Applause]
mr speaker i think when are when are
they scottish
sorry mr speaker when are the scottish
people going to hear an ounce of sense
from the scottish nationalism we both
can't stand up at the same time i'm
trying to be helpful
we've got to be more moderate and
taunting language jews pinocchio he's
not acceptable i'm sure the member
wishes to withdraw it quickly
mr speaker i will throw that but he
packs his bags and goes minister
withdrawn
sorry
you've withdrawn
you're winning
let's get on prime minister
withdrawal
[Applause]
is that your are you answering anything
the answer is that we're going to get on
the job maybe get on with it'll be nice
to hear an ounce of sense from the
scottish nationalist party awesome
competent government
regionals the london borough barnes is
surrounded by labour councils all of
which have higher council tax and have
abandoned weekly bin collections
so will the prime minister urge everyone
to come out on the 5th of may and vote
conservative in order to keep council
tax lower than labour and to protect our
weekly win collection
quite right mr speaker conservative
councils fix four times more potholes
recycle twice as much and conservative
councils mr speaker charge less
mr speaker the ministerial code states
that ministers have a duty to comply
with the law and to protect the
integrity of public life
the prime minister has broken the law
and repeatedly shown contempt for the
british public yes conservative mps
opposites seem content to decry the
principled honesty and integrity as they
unashamedly defend him the public want
him gone we want him gone when will he
do the right thing and resign
mr speaker i know why they want me gone
because uh this government is gonna get
on uh we are gonna get on and show why
this conservative government is going to
deliver for the british people uh
deliver uh fixing our costs of living
issues making sure that we solve our
long-term energy uh problems and and
delivering on everything that we
promised to do mr speaker and they have
absolutely no plan that's the difference
david thank you very much
mr speaker
on these benches we were elected to make
the most of our brexit freedoms
including including they don't like it
they don't like it
but including tackling immigration
illegal immigration securing our borders
and crackdown on the evil people
smuggling
trade does my right honourable friend
agree that our grand groundbreaking
partnership with rwanda will do just
that
well mr speaker i think it's part it is
a part of the solution and it's
something that as i said uh just now was
advocated in 2004 uh by uh the then home
secretary uh david blunkett uh a
blairite home secretary it's now
attacked in the most uh ludicrous terms
by the the current labor opposition who
are obviously as i just said corbin
easter's in islington suits
him thank you mr speaker
i wonder what the prime minister makes
of this quote
when a regime has been in power too long
when it has fatally exhausted the
patience of the people and when oblivion
finally beckons
across the world
you can rely on leaders of that regime
to act solely in the interests of
self-preservation
and not in the interest of the
electorate his words mr speaker daily
telegraph 28th of february 2011. does he
still agree yes or no
mr speaker
all i can say is that i i'm delighted
that she's a reader of the daily
telegraph
[Applause]
i think what she needs to do is keep
going to the end of the article that's
my advice
we now come to the 10-minute rule bill
well if you were one of those uh
predicting something of a change in tone
from the prime minister top of the class
well done gone was yesterday's condition
head held low you can perhaps understand
why uh under the face of some a pretty
pointed questioning for from secure
stamina the prime minister clearly felt
that he had to defend his position uh
some of it i think warmly welcomed by
the people behind him other parts of it
well let's ask our deputy political
editor sam kotzu will be here to take us
through the time warp to the tiny minds
of pmq's today what did you make of all
i mean certainly like this was not a
prime minister who was willing to come
to the house again and repeat yesterday
as mentioned he referred to secure
stamina as existing in a doctor who time
war
yes but this is the problem for boris
johnson boris johnson's game at the
moment is to try and move on from party
gay understandably um but this was a
much more sparky much more interesting
prime minister's questions than you get
quite a lot of the time frankly neil um
kia stammer was on better form and boris
johnson arguably slightly tetchier form
than i can remember for some time um
kirsten did what he doesn't always do
which is to have quite specific
questions which clearly got under the
prime minister's skin um uh we'll come
on to these in a moment he talked about
whether you know what the prime minister
said behind closed doors about the bbc
and the archbishop of canterbury uh last
night when he was meeting tory mps boris
johnson didn't like that um there was
the he denied seeing it in fact um he
well it's a bit more complicated than
that i'm sitting back go on tour okay so
boris johnson is a very clever
communicator what he often does is to
implant something in people's minds
without kind of specifically making an
allegation he sort of um so last night
as best we can understand he said and
i'm and i'm quite i'm i'm quoting what i
believe boris johnson said that there
was criticism from the bbc and senior
members of the clergy
which was less vociferous in their
condemnation
on easter sunday of president putin than
they were of our policy on illegal
immigration
now that's less punchy than perhaps the
headlines in some of the newspapers um
but
boris johnson is implanting the idea
that in some way
uh some senior members of the clergy are
uh
you know creating some kind of false
equivalence they of course would deny
that but nor did boris johnson quite say
it so when he stands up in the house he
can deny he says what the headline said
but he's planting an idea he's creating
that equivalence it's very clever
communication unless you can see right
through it i think that's a little bit
of a guide so boris johnson said that
kirsten was out of his tiny mind to
suggest that he was criticizing the
ukraine coverage of the bbc
absolutely true
boris johnson didn't he was criticizing
the rwanda immigration plan of the
coverage of the bbc which is something
completely different but you know
what i think is more interesting and
more important about that is the use of
the phrase tiny mind boyce johnson is
capable of being far more eloquent than
a sort of you know base rubbishing a
playground
exactly it's the kind of thing i'd throw
you off at that's you understand
but it's not something that you
necessarily expect from boris johnson
who is good at this kind of thing and i
think that is a sign that today
kierstarma managed to get under boris
johnson's skin let's start with that
question that kind of perhaps threw him
a little bit and it was about his former
director of communications then went off
to run cop 26 after
she got caught on camera in the briefing
room that you were supposed to attend
but which has been closed down answering
a question about a party in downstream
and struggling to answer that question
exactly why did allegra stratton resign
ask kierstarma
boris johnson replied with a palm of
praise to allegra stratton said she did
a wonderful job she came up with key
slogans behind the climate change coffee
she's a wonderful person now
she is the only person to have resigned
over partygate and therefore this is an
incredibly unhelpful episode for boris
johnson but the truth is those of us
with long enough memories to remember
december the 8th 2021 will remember that
actually at the time on the day of
allegra stratton's resignation which he
accepted which he didn't particularly
acknowledge today his tone was
incredibly different about her he said
back then i understand and share the
anger up and down the country at seeing
number 10 staff seemingly to make
lockdown
light of lockdown measures i can
understand how infuriating it must be to
think that the people who have been
setting the rules have not been
following the rules because i was also
furious to see that clip i apologize
unreservedly for the offence that it has
caused up and down the country and i
apologize for the impression that that
gives now arguably what we've seen since
there is way worse we now have the prime
minister himself fine for breaking
covert restrictions that he himself
implemented uh and all the other things
that we've seen
right now um
but allegra stratton ultimately resigned
for joking about something that she
regarded in that briefing room as being
indefensible footage of that was leaked
now we've got the prime minister not
residing for actually having committed
one of those offences and i think that
that comparison the circumstances under
which he's um accepted other people's
resignations name-checking of course as
kierstein did neil ferguson um the top
scientist who had to go because of his
affair with his uh uh lover at the
height of lockdown uh matt hancock who
also had a relationship uh with an aide
that resulted in his resignation these
comparisons do not flatter boris
johnson's political situation forcing
him to sidestep these questions of
equivalence equivalence what boris
doesn't like how brussels likes to play
politics with with equivalence and false
equivalence but he doesn't like it when
it's done to him
you you've had to check the tape we've
gone to var but did we actually today
get from the prime minister a concession
that he accepts
that he has broken the law that's why he
got a penalty
um boris johnson was asked by kierstarma
do you accept you broke the law boris
johnson replied yes mr speaker i've been
very clear and i have accepted the
police's view so insomuch as you take
the yes mr speaker to refer to accepting
the breaking of the law then perhaps we
did um uh grammatical
specialists could possibly read that
sentence in a number of ways i'll leave
it for others to cast the ultimate
judgment nicely sidestep sam for now
thanks very much indeed
well of course at the heart of all of
this are the sacrifices that many people
across the country made during the
pandemic i'm joined now by dr salia asan
an emergency medicine doctor who worked
in intensive care awards during that
time and who lost her father to covet
also joining us louise bennett whose son
fred died of leukemia in may 2020 just
over a week after his 14th birthday
covered restrictions of course at